Hi everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference, held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague, Kim Mills, was a guest host. We hope you enjoy this episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the breadth and depth of psychological science. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm speaking.
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在2019年10月于华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会（APA）“技术、思维与社会”会议期间录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。你好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探索心理科学的广度与深度。我是主持人金·米尔斯，我正在……
speaking to you from APA's annual Technology, Mind, and Society Conference in Washington, D.C., a cross-disciplinary meeting to discuss psychology's role in developing and advancing everything from virtual reality to artificial intelligence, to robotics, to the Internet of Things. My guest today is Dr. Susan Persky, a psychologist who works at the National Human Genome Research Institute at the National Institutes of Health. She is an associate investigator and head of the immersive virtual environment testing unit where she directs the immersive virtual environment testing area within the social and behavioral research branch, which sounds intimidating, but what she does on a day-to-day basis is apply virtual reality to biomedical research. She also covers
在华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会年度“技术、思维与社会”会议上为您进行报道。这是一场跨学科会议，旨在探讨心理学在开发和推进从虚拟现实到人工智能、机器人技术以及物联网等各个领域中的作用。我今天的嘉宾是苏珊·珀斯基（Susan Persky）博士，她是一位心理学家，在美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）下属的国家人类基因组研究所工作。她是副研究员，也是沉浸式虚拟环境测试部门的负责人，负责指导社会与行为研究分支下的沉浸式虚拟环境测试领域。这听起来可能有些深奥，但她日常的工作其实是将虚拟现实应用于生物医学研究。她还负责……
NIH research into communication and decision-making in patients as they react to simulations of environments that might trigger healthy or unhealthy behaviors. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Persky. Thanks for having me. So let's start by talking about the work that you presented at APA's annual Technology Mind and Society Conference. It involves using a virtual reality buffet to measure and understand how parents teach their children about food and eating. Can you tell us a little more about the project? Yeah, absolutely. So the genesis of the buffet was really back when a colleague and I were doing a study where we were trying to understand how talking to parents about genetics, genomic-based risk for a child might influence that.
美国国立卫生研究院关于患者在面对可能引发健康或不健康行为的环境模拟时，其沟通和决策过程的研究。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，珀斯基博士。谢谢你的邀请。那么，让我们先谈谈你在美国心理学会年度“技术、思维与社会”会议上展示的研究成果。它涉及使用虚拟现实自助餐来衡量和理解父母如何教导孩子关于食物和饮食的知识。你能多介绍一下这个项目吗？好的，没问题。其实，这个自助餐项目的起源是当时我和一位同事正在进行一项研究，我们试图了解向父母传达关于遗传学、基于基因组的儿童风险信息，可能会如何影响……
parent's feeding behavior. So the choices that a parent would make for a child once they sort of learned about this genomic risk information. And traditionally, we might use a questionnaire to assess that behavior or, you know, the gold standard might be to go in a real feeding environment and assess behavior. But given all the potential downsides of the existing measures, we decided that creating a virtual reality-based buffet would be a really good way to go in terms of measuring parent feeding behavior in the lab. So the work. that I presented is really focused on how that buffet came to be, how we validated the buffet, and then some of the work that we've done subsequently to that, where we've used it to measure
父母的喂养行为。也就是说，父母在了解了这些基因组风险信息后，会为孩子做出什么样的选择。传统上，我们可能会使用问卷来评估这种行为，或者，你知道，黄金标准可能是进入真实的喂养环境来评估行为。但考虑到现有测量方法的所有潜在缺点，我们认为创建一个基于虚拟现实的自助餐，将是衡量实验室中父母喂养行为的一种非常好的方式。因此，我展示的研究主要集中在这个自助餐是如何产生的，我们是如何验证它的，以及随后我们所做的一些工作，我们用它来衡量……
parents' responses to genomic information and other elements of parent feeding behavior. So as I understand it, in addition to the virtual buffet, you also have parents serve kids real food, and that when they do that, they tend to serve, I think, more of the real food to their kids than the virtual food, do you have any idea why they do this? Right. So we did a validation study of our virtual buffet where we worked with the metabolic kitchen in the NIH Clinical Center. It was a really interesting process. We made a bowl, a serving bowl of pasta with tomato sauce that was basically identical to our virtual reality-based pasta. And that way we could compare how much parents served for their child for lunch from the real pasta versus from the virtual pasta. And so what we found
父母对基因组信息的反应以及父母喂养行为的其他要素。据我了解，除了虚拟自助餐，你还让父母给孩子提供真实的食物，而且当他们这样做时，他们似乎给孩子提供的真实食物比虚拟食物要多，你知道他们为什么这样做吗？是的。我们对虚拟自助餐进行了验证研究，我们与美国国立卫生研究院临床中心的代谢厨房合作。这是一个非常有趣的过程。我们制作了一碗番茄酱意大利面，它与我们基于虚拟现实的意大利面基本相同。这样我们就可以比较父母在午餐时为孩子提供的真实意大利面和虚拟意大利面的量。我们发现……
was a really good correlation. So what we really care about is that the parents who are the sort of the low servers in terms of the amount of pasta in VR are also the low servers in reality and the high servers are the high servers. Because we're always comparing different experimental conditions. We're always comparing parents within a study to each other.
相关性非常好。我们真正关心的是，那些在虚拟现实中提供较少意大利面的父母，在现实中也是提供较少的人；而提供较多的人，在现实中也是提供较多的人。因为我们总是在比较不同的实验条件。我们总是在研究中比较不同的父母。
So we care much more about the correlation. But in terms of the actual amount of pasta served, we do definitely find that, at least in that study, parents served more real pasta than virtual pasta. I would speculate that that might be because the serving amounts that you're able to choose in the virtual reality buffet are relatively small. And we did that on purpose because we wanted to make the measure very sensitive. If, you know, every time a parent goes and chooses a serving of virtual pasta, you get, you know, six noodles or a huge scoop of noodles that really limits the variability in the measure. because then the parents might choose two scoops of pasta or four,
所以我们更关心相关性。但就实际提供的意大利面数量而言，我们确实发现，至少在那项研究中，父母提供的真实意大利面比虚拟意大利面多。我推测这可能是因为你在虚拟现实自助餐中能够选择的份量相对较小。我们这样做是有意为之，因为我们希望使测量非常敏感。如果，你知道，每次父母去选择一份虚拟意大利面时，你得到的是，你知道，六根面条或者一大勺面条，这确实限制了测量中的变异性。因为那样的话，父母可能会选择两勺意大利面或四勺，
but they're not going to go between four and 12, right? So we really cut down on the amount of pasta you get per serving in VR. In the real world, we used a small serving spoon, so again, the serving sizes would be small, but parents could really try to heap more pasta onto that serving spoon. And a lot of them really did that. So I think it was actually just by virtue of some characteristics of the VR environment that we created for a purpose, but it may hamper a little bit the ability to say
但他们不会在四勺和十二勺之间选择，对吧？所以我们确实减少了在虚拟现实中每份提供的意大利面数量。在现实世界中，我们使用了一个小汤匙，所以同样，份量会很小，但父母确实可以尝试在那个汤匙上堆更多的意大利面。而且他们中的很多人确实这样做了。所以我认为这实际上只是因为我们为了某种目的而创建的虚拟现实环境的一些特征，但这可能会稍微妨碍我们去断言……
if a parent serves 300 calories of pasta, in the real world, they'll serve 300 calories of pasta in VR, which isn't something we really feel like we need to be able to say to have it be a valid measure for our purposes. So you found parents serve different amounts of food to boys than to girls, and I'm just wondering why they do that. Like are parents unconsciously trying to keep their girls thinner because of, you know, the stereotype that girls have to be thin in our society to be beautiful? Does that play any role? So it's a really interesting thing that I didn't know before we did this study is that it's actually recommended that you serve more calories to boys than girls. If you go and look at the calories serving recommendations for children.
如果一位父母在现实世界中为孩子提供了300卡路里的意大利面，那么在虚拟现实中他们也会提供300卡路里的意大利面，这并不是我们认为为了使它成为一种有效的测量方法所必须能够断言的事情。所以你发现父母给男孩和女孩提供的食物量不同，我只是想知道他们为什么这样做。比如，父母是否在潜意识里试图让他们的女儿更瘦，因为，你知道，社会上认为女孩必须瘦才漂亮的刻板印象？这起作用吗？这是一个非常有趣的事情，在做这项研究之前我并不知道，实际上建议给男孩提供的卡路里比女孩多。如果你去查看儿童卡路里摄入建议的话。
So, you know, one might say, oh, well, maybe moms are just following, you know, dietary guidelines. We think that's really unlikely to be the case. You know, what we found in the research we did there is that when we look at the factors that predict how much food the moms are serving to their boys versus their girls, we see a lot of psychological predictors that can, you know, tell us something about what they're choosing for their girls, such as their concern about weight, such as their reported restriction. There are a lot of things that are kind of going into that serving behavior. For boys, we found very, very little that predicted moms serving behavior. for the boys. And so, you know, we think that the moms are just thinking a little bit harder about
所以，你知道，有人可能会说，哦，好吧，也许妈妈们只是在遵循，你知道，饮食指南。我们认为这种情况不太可能。你知道，我们在研究中发现，当我们观察预测妈妈们给男孩和女孩提供多少食物的因素时，我们看到了很多心理预测指标，它们可以，你知道，告诉我们一些关于她们为女儿选择食物的信息，比如她们对体重的担忧，比如她们报告的限制行为。有很多因素在影响那种喂养行为。对于男孩，我们发现几乎没有什么因素能预测妈妈们的喂养行为。所以，你知道，我们认为妈妈们只是在……
what they're serving their girls. And it is probably a lot of those sort of societal expectations that are feeding into that sort of more considered behavior when choosing for girls. And you had both parents, moms and dads serving kids, right? So in the particular study that we're talking about now, it was only mothers. That's where we started. We've done subsequently a lot of research where we've also included fathers. It turns out that recruiting fathers, just lone fathers, not, you know, diads to do research of this type is a really difficult endeavor. We've had a lot of trouble getting dads into our lab. We're actually going to publish some work we've done looking at how to recruit fathers for this kind of research. But some of my work has shown that
她们为女儿提供食物时考虑得更多。这很可能与那些社会期望有关，这些期望促使她们在为女儿选择食物时表现出更深思熟虑的行为。而且你让父母双方，妈妈和爸爸都参与了喂养，对吧？所以，在我们现在讨论的这项特定研究中，只有母亲参与。这就是我们开始的地方。后来我们做了很多研究，也包括了父亲。事实证明，招募父亲，仅仅是父亲，而不是，你知道，夫妻双方来做这类研究，是一项非常困难的工作。我们在让爸爸们进入实验室方面遇到了很多困难。我们实际上准备发表一些我们所做的研究，探讨如何为这类研究招募父亲。但我的一些工作表明……
we do see different feeding patterns between mothers and fathers. And so it is really, really important that we look at fathers. Well, we should tell our listeners if there are some dads out there in the D.C. area who maybe want to volunteer to come to your clinic, how do they reach you? Absolutely. Well, we're at the Genome Institute and, you know, we're on the website. Please send me an email because we're always looking for fathers to participate in our research. So have you looked at whether the virtual buffet has an impact on the parents' eating habits as well?
我们确实看到母亲和父亲之间的喂养模式不同。所以，观察父亲确实非常非常重要。好吧，如果华盛顿特区地区有一些爸爸们可能想自愿来你的诊所，我们应该告诉听众他们如何联系你？当然。我们在基因组研究所，你知道，我们在网站上有信息。请给我发电子邮件，因为我们一直在寻找父亲参与我们的研究。那么，你是否研究过虚拟自助餐是否也会对父母自身的饮食习惯产生影响？
We haven't. I think anecdotally using the virtual buffet probably would have an impact, only because you know, we spend a lot of time with the virtual buffet when we're preparing studies or right now we're in the midst of developing a new version of the VR buffet. And we, when we're done with our VR buffet, we crave all the foods that look delicious on that buffet. We had a running joke where someone would just have to run down to the coffee shop and buy chocolate chip cookies when we spend a long time with the buffet. So, you know, I think exposure to delicious looking food cues will have an influence on a lot of people. But in terms of sort of differences in, you know, what we show them on
我们还没有研究过。我认为，从轶事角度来看，使用虚拟自助餐可能会产生影响，仅仅是因为你知道，我们在准备研究时会花很多时间在虚拟自助餐上，或者现在我们正处于开发新版虚拟现实自助餐的过程中。当我们完成虚拟现实自助餐的工作时，我们都会渴望那些在自助餐上看起来很美味的食物。我们有一个惯例笑话，就是当我们花很长时间在自助餐上时，总得有人跑去咖啡店买巧克力曲奇。所以，你知道，我认为接触看起来很美味的食物线索会对很多人产生影响。但就，你知道，我们在……
the buffet, that's work that I think would be really interesting, but work that hasn't been done yet. So you talked about the buffet being very tantalizing. You work with it all day and then you need to have something to eat. I mean, what does this buffet look like? Right. So we've basically developed it to be basically a buffet restaurant. So if you think about, you know, going in to an all-you-can-eat buffet. We give parents a virtual tray and a virtual plate, and we've created it to have foods that are very palatable to children, foods that children eat,
自助餐上展示的内容的差异而言，我认为这将是非常有趣的研究，但目前还没有做过。所以你提到自助餐非常诱人。你整天都在和它打交道，然后你需要吃点东西。我的意思是，这个自助餐看起来是什么样的？是的。我们基本上把它开发成了一个自助餐厅。所以如果你想到，你知道，去吃自助餐。我们给父母一个虚拟托盘和一个虚拟盘子，我们创建它时包含了对孩子非常有吸引力的食物，孩子们吃的食物，
but also to have a good variety of calorie and nutrient densities. And so they basically have their virtual tray. They walk around on each side of the parent. There are buffet tables that have things like chicken nuggets, grilled chicken, grapes and steamed carrots, and black beans and applesauce. There's a huge variety of foods that parents can choose from to make a plate for their child. Parents walk around with a virtual reality controller, and they're able to select different foods
同时也包含了各种各样的卡路里和营养密度。所以他们基本上有他们的虚拟托盘。他们在父母的每一侧走动。有自助餐桌，上面有鸡块、烤鸡、葡萄、蒸胡萝卜、黑豆和苹果酱等食物。父母可以从种类繁多的食物中进行选择，为孩子制作一份餐盘。父母拿着一个虚拟现实控制器走动，他们能够选择不同的食物，
and put small servings of those foods on the plate, and then they can keep selecting to make bigger servings of the foods. And there's no limit they can make the plate as big as they want? So there is a technical limit to how much food can end up on the plate. That's actually something we're working on with a new version, is making that technical limit larger, because parents are choosing more food in some cases than we expected, especially for older children. But they can actually put food back, which is not something I recommend in a real buffet.
并将这些食物的小份量放在盘子上，然后他们可以继续选择以制作更大份量的食物。而且没有限制，他们可以把盘子做得尽可能大吗？所以，盘子上最终能放多少食物是有技术限制的。这实际上是我们正在与新版本一起努力解决的问题，即扩大那个技术限制，因为在某些情况下，父母选择的食物比我们预期的要多，特别是对于年龄较大的孩子。但他们实际上可以把食物放回去，这不是我在真实自助餐中推荐的做法。
But in the virtual buffet, it's fine. It's actually something that we measure. And then they choose a drink size, and they choose from a variety of drinks, like soda and milk and juice and water. And then they select a cash register to indicate that they're finished choosing food for their child. And so we then,
但在虚拟自助餐中，这没问题。这实际上是我们测量的内容。然后他们选择饮料的大小，他们从各种饮料中进行选择，比如苏打水、牛奶、果汁和水。然后他们选择一个收银台来表示他们已经为孩子选好了食物。所以我们随后，
have information about the process through which they've chosen all those foods, the timing, the order, where they've walked. And then we also, of course, have information about everything that ends up on the plate. And we've calculated, you know, calories, fat, all the kind of nutrient content that you would want to based on the servings that they've chosen. So are you using smells, food smells, in association with the virtual buffet? We are. In the very last study we did with the virtual buffet, we actually pumped in french fry smell to the room. It was, you know, we felt like it was kind of low-hanging fruit and something that would be fairly easy for us to do and might make people feel more present in the buffet environment. Interestingly, very few of our
就有了关于他们选择所有这些食物的过程的信息，时间、顺序、他们走过的地方。当然，我们还有关于最终放在盘子上的所有东西的信息。我们已经计算了，你知道，卡路里、脂肪，所有你想要的营养成分，基于他们选择的份量。那么，你是否在虚拟自助餐中使用了气味，食物的气味？我们用了。在我们用虚拟自助餐做的最后一项研究中，我们实际上向房间里泵入了炸薯条的味道。你知道，我们觉得这是一种低垂的果实，是我们相当容易做到的事情，而且可能会让人们觉得在自助餐环境中更有存在感。有趣的是，我们很少有……
participants actually noticed it. You know, my research assistants were basically choking on the stuff. You know, they were complaining, could we turn it down? And I'm like, no, I think we better leave it up. But really, our participants rarely smelled it. Now, those who did smell it could tell you exactly what it was. They knew they smelled French fries. But most people didn't smell it. And we're actually doing some follow-up experiments now to learn more about, you know, why didn't people smell it? And, you know, are there different sense that might work better? So that's something we're actually working on right now is how to best integrate smell into these kinds of virtual reality environments. So you're talking about the influence of genomics,
参与者真正注意到了它。你知道，我的研究助理基本上被那味道呛到了。你知道，他们抱怨说，我们能把它调小吗？我说，不，我想我们最好保持原样。但实际上，我们的参与者很少闻到它。现在，那些确实闻到它的人可以准确地告诉你它是什么。他们知道他们闻到了炸薯条的味道。但大多数人没有闻到。我们现在实际上正在做一些后续实验，以了解更多关于，你知道，为什么人们没有闻到它？以及，你知道，是否有不同的气味可能效果更好？所以这就是我们目前正在研究的内容，即如何最好地将气味整合到这类虚拟现实环境中。所以你在谈论基因组学的影响，
and that might be a term that some of our listeners don't fully understand. So can you explain what that means and how that relates to what you've been doing? Absolutely. So most listeners will be familiar with genetics, which we use to talk about individual genes. So if we think about, you know, the BRCA gene, which a lot of people are familiar with, that's one gene. Which is around breast cancer. Right. Yeah, it's around breast cancer risk. So that's genetic. So that's genetic. But genomics is really all of the genes taken together. So one's entire genome, all of your DNA, and the way that it interacts with the environment. And so that's what we consider to be genomics.
这可能是一些听众不太完全理解的术语。所以你能解释一下这意味着什么，以及它与你一直在做的事情有什么关系吗？当然。大多数听众会熟悉遗传学，我们用它来谈论个体基因。所以如果我们想到，你知道，BRCA基因，很多人都很熟悉，那是一个基因。它是关于乳腺癌的。对。是的，它是关于乳腺癌风险的。所以那是遗传的。所以那是遗传的。但基因组学实际上是所有基因的总和。所以一个人的整个基因组，你所有的DNA，以及它与环境相互作用的方式。这就是我们认为的基因组学。
And when you talk about obesity risk, eating behavior, you know, these sorts of things, we are really talking about genomics because there isn't one gene that influences one type of eating behavior or one gene that influences, you know, risk of obesity later in life to any sort of great extent. It's really about all of the genes kind of working together, small effects of a lot of genes that are going to influence these things. And so for that reason, we tend to talk a lot more about sort of overall risk or overall patterns in the way people's genetics and genomics influence risk. Because we know that things like obesity risk have a lot of genomic elements in it. So we know that body weight is very highly inhalinging.
当你谈论肥胖风险、饮食行为，你知道，这些事情时，我们实际上是在谈论基因组学，因为没有一个基因会影响一种饮食行为，也没有一个基因会影响，你知道，以后生活中患肥胖症的风险，达到任何巨大的程度。这实际上是所有基因共同作用的结果，许多基因的小效应将影响这些事情。因此，出于这个原因，我们倾向于更多地谈论，你知道，整体风险或人们的遗传学和基因组学影响风险的方式的整体模式。因为我们知道像肥胖风险这样的事情有很多基因组元素在里面。所以我们知道体重在很大程度上是……
inherited from parent to child. But we don't know all of the particular genes that influence it. And then what's the application after all of this? Does the parent get some sort of a readout of this is what you did and you're feeding your kid too much of this and not enough of that? And maybe they'll go home and they'll behave differently? So no, we haven't done that. So we're not being prescriptive in this. We're really using it as a research measure to look at how the messages or the information that we've given the parent might influence their behavior. though using it maybe as an intervention tool or an educational tool is definitely something that we've talked about and considered.
从父母遗传给孩子。但我们并不知道所有影响它的特定基因。那么这一切之后的应用是什么？父母会得到某种关于你做了什么，你给孩子喂了太多这个，不够那个的反馈吗？也许他们会回家并表现得不同？所以不，我们还没有那样做。所以我们在这方面不是规定性的。我们真的把它作为一个研究测量工具，来看看我们给父母的信息或知识可能会如何影响他们的行为。虽然把它作为一种干预工具或教育工具绝对是我们讨论和考虑过的事情。
We have a limited amount of time and energy on our part, but what we're doing right now is developing a new version of the buffet that will be a little bit easier for us to share with other researchers in the hopes that some other labs might take up the mantle and do some of the more sort of interventional work that you're talking about. So then what is the actual application? So the actual application is as a behavioral measure. So then when we give parents information, you know, randomize them to condition, say, you know, some parents don't receive personalized obesity risk for their child. Some receive other, you know, different kinds of personalized risk.
我们自己的时间和精力有限，但我们现在正在做的是开发一个新版本的自助餐，这将使我们更容易与其他研究人员分享，希望其他实验室能够接过接力棒，做一些你所说的更具干预性的工作。那么实际的应用是什么？所以实际的应用是作为一个行为测量工具。所以当我们给父母信息时，你知道，随机分配他们到某种条件，比如，你知道，一些父母没有收到关于他们孩子个性化肥胖风险的信息。一些收到其他，你知道，不同种类的个性化风险。
And then we can look at how that message leads to differences in feeding behavior. So following a study, we'll say, okay, well, parents in this condition fed fewer calories than parents in that condition or, you know, chose more sugar-sweetened beverages, you know, or other outcomes like that. So we're able to actually look at how the information that we might give parents results in differences in feeding behavior. So some of your other work involves applying genomics to weight management and primary care. Can you talk a little bit about what that means exactly? Sure. So some of my other work uses virtual reality as sort of a rough clinical simulation to look at how giving information about genomics and weight might influence patients. Sometimes we flip it
然后我们可以观察这种信息如何导致喂养行为的差异。所以在一项研究之后，我们会说，好吧，处于这种条件下的父母比处于那种条件下的父母喂养的卡路里更少，或者，你知道，选择了更多含糖饮料，你知道，或其他类似的结果。所以我们能够真正观察到我们可能给父母的信息如何导致喂养行为的差异。所以你的一些其他工作涉及将基因组学应用于体重管理和初级保健。你能谈谈这到底意味着什么吗？当然。我的一些其他工作使用虚拟现实作为一种粗略的临床模拟，来观察关于基因组学和体重的信息如何影响患者。有时我们把它……
on its head and we look at how giving information about genomics and weight to, say, a medical student might influence the way that that medical student talks to or treats a patient. And so when we're interested in studying medical students or doctors, we use a virtual reality human for the patient. And when we're interested in studying patients, we use a virtual reality human for the doctor. So the doctor might come in and in one condition might say, you know, you may not be aware of how much your weight is influenced by your genes, give some general information about heritability of weight and how some people sort of have a harder road to go when it comes to weight management and weight loss because of their genetics.
颠倒过来，我们观察向，比如，医学生提供关于基因组学和体重的信息如何影响该医学生与患者交谈或治疗患者的方式。所以当我们有兴趣研究医学生或医生时，我们使用虚拟现实人类作为患者。当我们有兴趣研究患者时，我们使用虚拟现实人类作为医生。所以医生可能会进来，在一种条件下可能会说，你知道，你可能没有意识到你的体重在多大程度上受到基因的影响，提供一些关于体重遗传性的一般信息，以及有些人如何因为他们的遗传学而在体重管理和减肥方面走得更艰难。
And so looking at how a message like that might influence a patient, in terms of health behavior is certainly one thing. There have been concerns, which I think have been largely overblown, but there are some areas where they are concerns, that people will say, oh, well, it's my genetics, you know, so nothing I can do. Whereas other people might say, okay, well, this might explain some things I've experienced, but I may just need to work harder than other people. So there are definitely different ways that people can understand that information and use it. One of the other things we look at is weight stigma in the clinical encounter, which is a huge
所以观察像这样的信息如何影响患者，在健康行为方面当然是一件事。人们一直有担忧，我认为这些担忧在很大程度上被夸大了，但在某些领域它们确实是担忧，人们会说，哦，好吧，这是我的遗传学，你知道，所以我无能为力。而其他人可能会说，好吧，这可能解释了我经历过的一些事情，但我可能只是需要比其他人更努力。所以人们确实有不同的方式来理解和使用这些信息。我们观察的另一件事是临床接触中的体重污名，这是一个巨大的……
issue in this country. So if a doctor talks about genetic factors in weight, does that influence how patients feel about the doctor and feel about what the doctor's saying, you know, and what we're finding is that it definitely can make the patient feel less stigmatized in the encounter and trust the doctor more if the doctor brings in issues around genetics and weight. Yeah. So I don't know if this is anecdotal or probably it is because I'm going to tell you an anecdote. So I was just talking to somebody recently about how a lot of people don't want to go to their doctors because they feel like they are overweight and they don't want to get a lecture from the doctor. Is that the sort of
在这个国家的问题。所以如果医生谈论体重中的遗传因素，这会影响患者对医生的感觉以及对医生所说的话的感觉吗，你知道，我们发现它绝对可以让患者在接触中感到不那么被污名化，如果医生引入关于遗传学和体重的问题，他们会更信任医生。是的。所以我不知道这是否是轶事，或者可能确实是，因为我要告诉你一个轶事。所以我最近刚和某人谈论很多人不想去看医生，因为他们觉得他们超重了，他们不想从医生那里得到说教。这是那种……
thing that you find is happening and that perhaps some of what you're working on could change that dialogue? Yeah, I mean, I think it is related because oftentimes in our other condition in that study is, you know, all about diet and exercise, which is sort of the standard information. But people know that. You know, if you go into the doctor and you get a lecture that, well, maybe you should, you know, eat less and move more. I mean, you know, is that helpful? I mean, it may be helpful for some people, but for other people, it will feel, you know, it won't feel good because, yes, of course, I know that. And for a lot of people, they feel like they're doing that or they've tried that. And it, you know, is legitimately very hard to maintain weight loss. So we feel like by talking
你发现正在发生的事情，也许你正在研究的一些东西可以改变那种对话吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为它是相关的，因为通常在我们那项研究的另一种条件下，你知道，全是关于饮食和运动，这是标准的建议。但人们知道这一点。你知道，如果你去看医生，你得到一个说教，好吧，也许你应该，你知道，少吃多动。我的意思是，你知道，这有帮助吗？我的意思是，它可能对某些人有帮助，但对其他人来说，它会感觉，你知道，它不会感觉良好，因为，是的，当然，我知道这一点。而且对于很多人来说，他们觉得他们正在这样做，或者他们已经尝试过那样做了。而且，你知道，维持减肥确实非常困难。所以我们觉得通过谈论……
about the genetic factors and sort of bringing that to light, you know, we don't see evidence that people are discouraged by it. Instead, we see evidence that people may actually feel better in the doctor-patient interaction and thereby may be more likely, you know, to sort of take the other information that comes with it a little bit better. So where do you think this field is going in the next five to ten years? Genomics or virtual reality or both? Well, we're both together. Since that's what you're doing. I mean, I think what is common to genomics and a virtual reality is that they both tend to move very fast. And I think we're in an area now where a lot of what we study with genomics, the reason we're studying it in virtual reality is because it's not happening clinically.
遗传因素并将其揭示出来，你知道，我们没有看到人们因此而气馁的证据。相反，我们看到证据表明人们在医患互动中实际上可能感觉更好，从而可能更有可能，你知道，稍微更好地接受随之而来的其他信息。那么你认为这个领域在未来五到十年内会走向何方？基因组学还是虚拟现实，还是两者兼有？好吧，我们两者结合。因为这就是你正在做的事情。我的意思是，我认为基因组学和虚拟现实的共同点是它们都倾向于发展得非常快。而且我认为我们现在处于这样一个领域，我们用基因组学研究的很多东西，我们在虚拟现实中研究它的原因是因为它在临床上并没有发生。
So we're not going into the doctor and getting information about our genetic risk for overweight and obesity for good reason. The science isn't there. But there is a lot of movement around polygenic risk scores. So this is the idea that you take a lot of genes and you kind of take them all together and use that to determine some manner of risk. Well, some people who have very, very high polygenic risk scores, you know, are at increased risk for obesity. And this has already started to work its way into clinic after I've, you know, I've seen maybe a year of research on this. I mean, this is, it happens so quickly that we're really trying to figure out best practices for communication before these things are sort of widespread. And I think that's also
所以我们没有去看医生并获得关于我们超重和肥胖遗传风险的信息，这是有充分理由的。科学还没有达到那个水平。但围绕多基因风险评分有很多动向。所以这就是你采取很多基因，你把它们全部放在一起，并用它来确定某种风险的想法。好吧，一些具有非常非常高多基因风险评分的人，你知道，患肥胖症的风险增加。这已经开始在我，你知道，我看到也许一年的研究之后进入临床。我的意思是，这发生得太快了，以至于我们真的在试图在这些事情变得普遍之前找出沟通的最佳实践。而且我认为这也是……
true for virtual reality. We're trying to figure out, you know, what are the best ways to use virtual reality as a tool. Some of my work also looks at best practices around privacy, around validation and evaluation of virtual reality applications, you know, trying to kind of get these things set before virtual reality really takes off in the clinical space. There are definitely projections, at least economically, that virtual reality is poised to be a huge player in the healthcare market.
虚拟现实的真实情况。我们正在试图找出，你知道，使用虚拟现实作为工具的最佳方式是什么。我的一些工作也着眼于围绕隐私、围绕虚拟现实应用的验证和评估的最佳实践，你知道，试图在虚拟现实真正进入临床空间之前把这些事情搞定。绝对有预测，至少在经济上，虚拟现实有望成为医疗保健市场的一个巨大参与者。
Well, virtual and augmented reality, so, you know, other types of extended reality or spatial computing, as people are calling them. You know, are poised to be a really big player, But there are a lot of issues that we want to get to on the ground floor before both of these things become very, very widespread. So I would say both of these things are poised for you to see them a lot more in the coming five to 10 years. And so a lot of what we're working on is trying to figure out what's the best way to present them. So you piqued my interest.
好吧，虚拟和增强现实，所以，你知道，其他类型的扩展现实或空间计算，正如人们所称呼它们的那样。你知道，有望成为一个非常大的参与者，但在两者变得非常非常普遍之前，有很多问题是我们想要在基层解决的。所以我可以说这两者都准备好让你在未来五到十年内看到它们更多。所以我们正在做的很多工作是试图找出呈现它们的最佳方式是什么。所以你引起了我的兴趣。
You mentioned privacy. What's the work that you're doing around privacy and VR? So a lot of the work that we do really focuses on behavioral movement or behavior in VR as an outcome measure. And as a researcher that is incredibly powerful. So I can look at how somebody walks around the VR buffet, choosing foods, and that tells me something about their psychological state. So something we're finding is that when the parents sort of move more around the virtual buffet, they feel less guilty afterwards. We think they felt like they tried harder. You know, they tried harder to pick a healthy meal for their child, and therefore they don't feel as much guilt.
你提到了隐私。你在虚拟现实隐私方面正在做什么工作？所以我们所做的很多工作确实集中在行为运动或虚拟现实中的行为作为结果测量。作为一名研究人员，这非常强大。所以我可以观察某人如何在虚拟现实自助餐中走动，选择食物，这告诉了我一些关于他们的心理状态的信息。所以我们发现的一件事是，当父母在虚拟自助餐中走动更多时，他们事后感到内疚感更少。我们认为他们觉得他们尝试得更努力了。你知道，他们更努力地为他们的孩子挑选健康的餐点，因此他们没有感到那么多的内疚。
you know, about feeding practices and so on. So if we as a researcher can use these tools to find out, you know, things about people's psychological states or their health, there's research showing that the way people move around a virtual reality environment can tell you something about potentially cognitive decline, other health conditions. So there are a lot of researchers who think that biometric data coming out of virtual reality is health data.
关于喂养习惯等等。所以如果我们作为研究人员可以使用这些工具来找出，你知道，关于人们心理状态或健康的事情，有研究表明人们在虚拟现实环境中走动的方式可以告诉你关于潜在认知能力下降、其他健康状况的事情。所以有很多研究人员认为来自虚拟现实的生物识别数据是健康数据。
And so there are concerns, you know, about what our company is going to do with the data. You know, for us, we're bound by an IRB. We're going to use the data responsibly, but that's not necessarily the case for everybody who might have access to similar data. Well, that's really interesting. What you're doing is very important work,
所以有担忧，你知道，关于公司将如何处理这些数据。你知道，对我们来说，我们受机构审查委员会（IRB）的约束。我们将负责任地使用这些数据，但这对于可能获得类似数据的每个人来说并不一定如此。好吧，这真的很有趣。你正在做的工作是非常重要的工作，
especially because, as we know, we're dealing with an obesity epidemic in our country and anything that you can do to help mitigate that, of course, is going to be very, very welcome. So I appreciate your talking to us today. Oh, thank you. So before we sign off here, I just want to remind our listeners that we at Speaking of Psychology want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org.
特别是正如我们所知，我们正在处理我们国家的肥胖流行病，任何你能做出的帮助减轻这种情况的事情，当然，都将是非常非常受欢迎的。所以我感谢你今天与我们交谈。哦，谢谢你。所以在我们结束之前，我只想提醒我们的听众，我们《心理学谈话》希望听到你们的声音。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
That's speaking of psychology all one word.org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. We would appreciate that. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the other informative podcast, APA Journal's dialogue about new psychological research and progress. notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.combeatingof psychology.org, and listen to more episodes. Thank you for listening. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 speaking of psychology 全部连在一起.org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他信息丰富的播客，美国心理学会期刊关于新心理学研究和进展的对话。关于心理学实践的笔记。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取你最喜爱的播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 www.combeatingof psychology.org，并收听更多剧集。感谢你的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。